the Joe Rogan experience well then also
like did the different environments that
people live in sort of dictate their
personnel like you're a desert guy right
you're from the desert yeah what is that
scorpion I'm I'm one of the few people I
know that's been bit by one have you
really yeah and as I I was going up to
Joshua Tree to this studio that's really
just a house and was that the one that
the guys showed in the thing you did
with Bourdain's yeah yeah uh-huh
Rancho de la Luna yeah and um but it's
magic is what's missing and I mean
everywhere every but and all that's left
is like what if you just when the tide
receded it was just the idiosyncratic
and the previously thrown away like all
in reborn and you know it's just got
that sort of feeling to it right so and
so I was driving up there and I know I'm
a desert boy I know that you're not
supposed to at night times when
everything comes out right because in
the day everyone is like oh really I
mean everything that walks or crawls is
like and so at night everyone everything
that walks or crawls goes right let's go
right and so you wear shoes if you do
not wear shoes you're it's you you have
made a mistake for sure and as soon as
we pull up to the Rancho in the dirt
parking lot I open up I open up the door
and I'm on the passenger side and I step
out and I'm going to reach for a 12-pack
of beer and something hit me on the foot
and I was like and I lift my foot and
there's this black or dark brownish like
a rootbeer e brown scorpion hanging from
my foot going hey hey hey hey hey
and I was like I I think it was like
like a really butch girl who's been
terrified for the first time like Wyatt
and I slapped it oh and I slap it off my
foot because that's my knee-jerk
reaction and I as I did that that's when
I screamed and jumped like
you know like a mouse or something right
in the car and in the door light of this
in the door light this scorpion hit the
ground like shuffled itself turned and
came right at me
Wow and was sort of like [ __ ] way too I
it's scared its back at you you imagine
being that little wanting to [ __ ] up
something as big as you who you'd have
to right you'd have it wouldn't be there
would be no bravado at all would be like
yeah like it would be it would be a true
believer right that in that moment I'm
like [ __ ] this thing and it is a hundred
percent sure it's gonna [ __ ] me up and
it was right because what am I gonna do
like I'm gonna hit this stinger with my
hands why this know what was the pain
light well at that time my understanding
of scorpions was in our desert Mojave
there's two types and one which is like
you know 24 hours of central nervous
system shutdown so they can't even give
you anything for the pain because the
thing that's that regulates that gets
like turn turned off or and so you're
just like from 24 hours you're in pain
that's that was my knowledge at that
time and the other one is akin to a bee
sting so when did you get well I had to
like track back this was before the
Internet and so I go inside and the
remedy at that time as Fred Drake who
rest in peace told me was to drink Jack
Daniels and put your foot in a bucket of
hot like burning hot water which is is a
little bit like having a horse on each
leg and they take off a different
direction because they get the hottest
water you can take and continue the pain
like it's that it's such a wives tale
it's almost like good the divorcees tale
or something like so I did that and
waited because I didn't know which one
it was
turns out that the 24 hours one is lives
in another desert in more autos to
Arizona and that it's not quite as as
I've described I'm just telling you what
I thought oh right right use and and it
was much like a bee sting but by the
time I realized that and it's swole up
it swole up
immediate and looked like it was gonna
keep going because it got to this golf
ball so fast mm-hmm that it was like
when will this stop right right but it
was like a bee sting but by the time
I've discovered that I was so drunk that
bee stings me sting you know so he's
just sitting there with your foot in a
bucket of hot water go scalding holding
liquor like it was like it said the
hotter it is the better and I was like
ah don't dump it imagine if the [ __ ]
real injury was you got third-degree
burns and your foot water there was
nothing wrong with it how mad would you
be my friend said you see the real
remedy is you grab a shark and you and
you totally forget about buddy mine was
in South America and he got bit by a
bullet ant he got hit by a bullet down
on his heel and he said it was he said
the pain was so bad but it was so
bewildering then after the pain was over
he couldn't figure out which foot got
bit ha ha wait because your brains going
like static he said you're it's so
confusing the pain so confusing it's
four hours do you think that because
anytime I've seen that online where it's
like you know you know I'm dingo piles
and I'm a bullet ant like Jesus man you
don't hang out with this person no one
would you sell love yeah like a handful
they pull yeah it's like a ritual that
young men have to do to reach the Brian
coming oh that's right yeah that's like
jumping off on how Bungie was invented
with no Bunge or no Boing no just no
Punk to be a man you jump up this thing
and it's like I'm starting to identify
as a yeah I I wonder what the bullet ant
thinks of all this if it's like now I
can never make any friends or what the
[ __ ] I think they're just violence in
insect form
don't you think that that's if there
ever was an alien that would be it would
be easy to assume this little bullet ant
in space that's just like it yeah and
then pushes so hard that there's two of
them
[Applause]